i'm laura ingram this is the ingram
angle we have a huge show for you
tonight a lot going on in washington and
beyond so let's dive right in
it's time to put americans first that's
the focus of tonight's angle
our elites and politics and the media
they really want you to know that they
care deeply about the afghan people so
much that they want to bring as many
afghans here to the united states as
possible accepting afghan refugees and
the willingness to accept more because
we have to do more the integration of
refugees in particular has been a a a
great american success story we're
actually quite good at it here in
america 50 000 afghan refugees uh in a
nation of over 300 million is is you
know not even a drop in the bucket
across the united states uh we are
seeing uh widespread support for
uh afghan refugees but for refugee
resettlement in general and while it's
certainly heart-wrenching to see the
needless suffering wherever it occurs in
the world it's just awful none of us
want to see that
but why is it that most of the same
people who you just saw on those clips
and all these politicians all the people
who were going on and on we're gonna let
everybody in the country why do they so
often ignore the very real suffering
happening here at home
you don't have to go to the afghan
provinces near bagram to see human
tragedy
you can see it not far from here in
baltimore
in the last three weeks five teenagers
have been shot there two of them fatally
one fifteen-year-old was gunned down in
the street in broad daylight
you don't have to go to kandahar to see
thousands living in constant fear of
violence
you can go to chicago to see that
sixteen were shot yesterday alone
including a seven-year-old boy who was
sitting in the back of his mom's car
it's all horrifying but we shouldn't be
surprised when the taliban terrorizes
afghans it's an islamic
fundamentalist extremist cult after all
come on
but what's our excuse
why aren't we more shocked why aren't we
demanding a response to the gangs and
the cartels the opioid all of it
terrorizing our neighborhoods right here
at home
in fact the left has only made matters
worse on the ground for the working
class here at home
they excuse riots they bailed out
criminals they endorsed the racist
radical agenda of blm
and democrats embedded the left on all
the issues of course they've helped make
all things worse at every turn
every person now demanding that we take
every afghan because we promise them
forgets that america's first promise is
to her own citizens
their safety their security and their
freedom
yet our border towns are being overrun
by released migrants because biden
refuses to do what's right on the border
they know that covet infected migrants
will infect american citizens and school
children this fall they know crime is
going to spike due to the million plus
migrants biden's already released into
the country
and they don't care
in fact their goal right now is to speed
up
the admission of these migrants into the
united states
just yesterday the administration
announced new rules to empower
bureaucrats who will now unilaterally
decide whether an illegal alien shows up
at our border should be allowed entry
into the united states
these open borders fanatics cannot be
trusted to safeguard our sovereignty and
enforce our laws
it's been obvious for a long time that
when you really think about it the
elites have pretty much had it with
americans
they like china a lot better many ways
remember regular americans well they
elected trump
they love their second amendment still
and they're far too religious
and at their core
they come from a kind of evil and racist
background
thus the more folks from other countries
who can come here
the better
even if we can't really vet them even if
they become wards of the state even if
they bring in more crime more violence
their extended family comes in third
cousins twice removed
to the left to the open borders
establishment
they're better than the old normal
the next three years we'll see blunder
after blunder from biden as his team
drifts from one crisis to the next
so what should conservatives in power do
now well the first thing we should do is
resist the democrat spending binge
that's happening that money is just
going to be wasted because biden's team
are not competent administrators
second thing we should do defend the
states who were trying to do the right
thing
you know red states are leading the way
economically and they're leading the way
to help protect our cherished freedoms
we cannot let biden bully them or the
inept blue state leaders drag them down
and third i think we should obviously
protect our border the gop may be
divided on the immigration amnesty issue
and refugees but
we should agree on the rule of law and
resist all immigration actions that are
not in strict accordance with duly past
laws
and fourth of course we have to fight
inflation that includes pressuring the
federal reserve to take more aggressive
action to stop inflation
and block disastrously big spending
bills
number five we should
continue to beat the drum for energy
independence we did it under trump it
was awesome we could do it again
lower energy prices mean more prosperity
it means more jobs for all americans
six we have to try to win in every state
how about that concept because for the
last 25 years republicans have focused
on winning a majority by capturing a
slim number of red states and then
picking up a few purple states here and
there it's really hard to do
and that strategy as we saw you know has
failed and it's allowed the hard left
to build solid support on the two coasts
that they dominate now that can't stand
for all their problems california and
new york are too important to concede to
the left they're both beautiful great
states we've got to win them back
if we really want to stop the socialists
who despise our country want to destroy
our country want to import more people
into our country to kind of balance out
or swap the old normal well we have to
see some big landslides
remember reagan fought for every state
and he eventually won 49 of them
we have to try to do the same
the time is right to take our religious
freedom our message of freedom and
prosperity to the voters on two coasts
and to the inner cities you bet they
have to hear our message too
people are suffering there from
incompetent leadership they're dying
there because of incompetent leadership
if we must live through a repeat of the
1970s with biden let's try to follow it
with a repeat of the 1980s
and that's the angle